[Music]
is that the funny thing about Trump and
people in the south it's like they took
really a New York really a New York
Democrat he's a good government it's
very clear he's a big government guy
he's happy to do all these executive
orders right a rich guy and elitist all
of those things I get it he was out of
the system he was out of the political
system so he thought it was an outsider
but they oh he's eight you know he's not
religious there's no reason to believe
that he believes in in Christianity the
one time he slept during the whole
campaign he went to Liberty University
and as a you know repeat the Corinthians
or whatever so it's like is that the
irony with them it's like oh yeah they
love him and then I I've actually I've
thought and I've talked a lot about this
exact thing because I and I feel so
naive about this now but like I was
genuinely stunned when Donald Trump
actually won I knew that there was and I
should have been because I'm from yeah
from where he won now if anybody I
should have been now I was like
cautioning people don't I'm like look
there's something real here but at the
end of the day I didn't think it would
happen and I was shocked and maybe the
biggest reason is and I felt this way
throughout his whole campaign I was
looking around like wait what is going
on because I this is not an assumption
or a like theory I promise you I know
this to be true if we could go back in
time like five six years ago but
whatever it was before he first went
after Obama for being a African Muslim
or whatever if we can go back to pre
that yeah and you polled rednecks rural
working-class Americans what do you
think about Donald Trump because don't
trust been famous for decades so what do
you think about Donald Trump the dude it
would have been almost universally
negative I promise you they would have
hated everything been they did hate
everything about him until like he got
in all this political [ __ ] and started
pandering to them but they were like
he's a he's an elitist silver spoon up
his ass Yankee thinks he's better than
everybody and thinks he's better made in
fact he knows everything and he's like
said big-city Democrat whatever like you
know they would have hated everything
about it and so the whole time I was you
know hit throughout his entire
I was looking around like really this
dude yeah really and what that says to
me or what I've told myself anyway to
make sense of it is that just goes to
show how desperate they were for a
champion of any kind like they were so
desperate for that that even Donald
Trump was good enough for them fill that
bill you know what I mean do you think
that's legit in a way because I get that
from a lot of people I mean I get mail
my audience is all over the place from
from far less people to anarchists to
everything everywhere but I get a lot
about people just saying you know what I
just the system it was just I've had it
I just had it you think that's like a
legit reason to vote for someone that
you may have nothing in common with that
you may think is a snake oil salesman is
that sometimes the right way to do it
not to me no I've never agreed with that
I've heard a lot of that to a lot of
people so when I was talking about a
little bit different when you talk about
like people in like my home town where
you know they blame NAFTA and I blame
the Clintons and whatever else for the
factory leaving and all this it's more
than just oh he's shaking the system up
it he was making promises directly to
them I'm going to bring your job back
and restore your livelihood and all this
stuff and that connected with people and
I don't think they thought he was a
snake oil salesmen or even if deep down
maybe they did a little bit I think they
lied to themselves and said and you know
deluded themselves into believing he
wasn't but I've also encountered a lot
of people who are like you just said
they're like you know what would shake
things up that's what we need there's
got something different whatever we nail
this it's systems broken let's mix it up
a little bit and I've never been on
board with that I got the general
premise of it yeah okay I kind of in
with you but in this iteration really
like this is how you want to manifest
that it's Donald Trump like nah man
give me the system for for eight more
years whatever and then let's get a
different maverick in there so isn't
this guy you know I never agreed with
that yeah do you think we just sort of
forget that all of us forgetting what
our political allegiances that we all
kind of just forget how actually good it
here is here yeah not to say that there
aren't problems of course yet with it
but but that is pretty damn good
man I've actually been trying to work on
a bit about that for a long time now
about but basically that about things
are better here now than they've been
for almost any group of people you can
name ever before and that's even true
for like you know rural white people
except things were better for them and
like you know a couple decades ago but
I'm saying if you go back further than
that right it wasn't to a great it was
absolutely hope they were sharecroppers
you know they had a little windows like
prosperity there where small-town
America was a real thing and
industrialism and whatever else outside
of that little window of time though
this is still better than they've had it
historically ever before and that's true
for most people and yes people
absolutely saw that it's also less
violent met now then it you know
historically than we've ever been it's
ever been before and people forget all
that to know like yeah that drives me
crazy sometimes because I think people
need to maintain that perspective like
you know the this is not Armageddon you
know what I mean like [ __ ] is crazy but
like we're still alright
you know yeah what do you make about the
Armageddon people because one of the
things I talk about here all time is the
free speech situation which i think is
going to get a lot worse I mean it's
very clear that a certain amount of
people now think it's okay to punch
Nazis or punch anyone you think might be
a Nazi and if someone's speaking at a
school you don't like you can burn down
the school and all that stuff yeah what
do we do so what us as the Liberals in
this situation that are supposed to
defend free speech what do we do to come
some of these people down I've been
trying to figure it out I don't know
that I got there yet yeah I'm not I'm
not sure either because any time I'm
gonna be honest any time that I've tried
to like touch on some of that because I
have and from my videos I've tried to
say things that are in line with what
we're talking about right now and they
never get the kind of response that my
other videos just railing on Trump or
the Ryder whatever dude everything I've
ever said in my videos I believe and I
that's my genuine thoughts you know but
anything that's ever been like kind of
challenging in that way they're always
like you know I can tell them like I can
see
you'll the internet been like no yeah
yeah let's see we don't want to hear all
that you know any like people just don't
want to hear it I was so but I thought
the less you're supposed to be the
tolerant side I know that they don't
need the tolerant people yeah and that's
and see that it's been that way for my
people my whole life like for years and
years I've been very aware of the
hypocrisy of liberals who you know of
whole or any kind of intolerance and
discrimination being so openly
prejudiced towards people like me yeah
and it's always been that where my whole
life it's been that way and I've always
thought that was [ __ ] like do you
not realize that that is still that's
still intolerant and it's always been
that way about you know poor white trash
rednecks whatever else but now it's like
spreading into this psyche they're
intolerant of anybody who doesn't agree
with them on every single thing you're
now you're you know you're a Nazi or
whatever and you know stoking the fires
of the patriarchy and all this [ __ ]
because you know what you were against
punching the Nottie right I don't want
to be worrying about imma get hit I
don't know anything I think that back I
don't give a [ __ ]
got a Nazi got punch yeah like like that
guy getting punched yeah
it's fine with me especially but you
know but I wish it would just happen in
a bar somewhere
they just whipped his ass yeah or
whatever because he probably needs a
bath with yeah but do I think that we
need to make it a thing we just go
around punching people that say things
we disagree with no absolutely not even
if they're Nazis it's like when they
sell you defended the Ku Klux Klan or
whatever in a court case once over a
freedom of speech issue and like that's
the way it should be you know I mean
that's fair like yeah that to hell with
the Klan that with Nazis obvious yeah
people think we're an Indiana Jones
again I know it's not it's ridiculous
like it has it has to go both ways it's
like and this is slightly different
subjects looks like on the topic of what
is and it's not okay to joke about
it's like Trey Parker and Matt Stone set
on South Park they tackled it and
they're like look either all of its okay
or none of it is and that's how I feel
about free speech in general
like you don't have to like the awful
[ __ ] that he's saying but this is
America and he has the right to say it
you know he just like we have the right
to say I have the right man cuz I I mean
I'd go after shitty white people as I
turned them hard all the time
and you know if I didn't have the
ability to do that I wouldn't be sitting
right now I wouldn't have a career I
just be doing whatever else and I
realized that so I'm not gonna be
hypocritical and say that you know only
I should have the right to do it because
I'm right he's wrong right what I mean
like and of course I believe that he's
wrong but it doesn't matter that's not
how it works you have to apply it you
know across the board consistently it's
almost like you have to have ideals even
when they're hard to have yeah crazy
right yeah how many years you've been
doing stand-up six and a half six and a
half and I get 12 years a stand-up
affordable Intel before I started doing
all this crazy shouldn't have told you
before how I got to start doing it again
now and I've been speaking to colleges
up and sort of working some stand-up in
because I see there's such a need for
people to say some uncomfortable things
but I'm curious in your six and a half
years have you seen the way language has
changed was there something that you
might have said six years ago that you
think now just because everyone's on
Twitter and snapchatting your whole set
and all that [ __ ] that you would be
afraid of saying it's hard as a comedian
sit here and say that I'm afraid of
saying anything but like but but yes
like one thing that bothers me is like
if I'm doing and I and I still do a lot
of this and I can feel people pull back
sometimes but usually it's oh it's okay
but if I'm doing a bit about something
that shitty people do or believe right
and like in the bit I'm talking about
this hypothetical racist or bigoted or
whatever and like you say you know like
if it's a homophobic thing and you in
the bit I say queer oh you're a [ __ ]
yeah ever but it's not me saying it I'm
talking about this guy saying it and
then I tear that dude apart right after
that for being shitty but it doesn't
matter to a lot of people just having
said the word they're like oh god no
yeah why would you do that it's like
you're not listening to me and I don't
like to sugarcoat things and act like
that's not how those people are
you know what I mean right that's what
that hypothetical dude would say and
that's the whole point of this whole bit
or whatever but none of that matters to
people all that matters is literally
just the word the buzzwords or whatever
and sometimes it's like buds ideas or
whatever you know what I mean that
you're just not allowed to joke about or
talk about no matter what yeah
absolutely hate that and that that's the
death of comedy because ya need satire
so you're trying to satire something to
point out hypocrisy or whatever you know
the Charlie Hebdo people people said
well they were mocking Mohammed they
were mocking extremists they're actually
a mirror and lies Rob I used to do a bit
about about the Transformers before they
were the movies like from the 80s
transformers how they were all different
racial people and I used to act out of
thing Jags he was the one black trans
woman tried to save n-word on stage yeah
and it would always get a huge laugh and
I remember one time that it got it
suddenly got a groan from a certain
amount of the crowd member thinking wow
I'm never going to tell that joke again
and I have no desire to say then where
he was just be acting out this fictional
robot you know just a grow bot that
doesn't exist but but satire and this
has gotten better for me for sure
because most people like my shows in
particular they sort of know what I'm
about know what they're getting into but
like man with this accent you literally
can't say black people you know to
really just relax people oh Jesus
what this is about to be terrible you
know to me like people immediately
recoil because of just the way it sounds
I mean yes I've definitely dealt with
that kind of thing and once one of my
first one my earliest videos I remember
I was acting out my
great-great-grandmother
you know who's dead that I said you know
she's dead if she was still alive she
wouldn't be comfortable eating cornbread
next to a colored boy right because she
wouldn't colored boys cleaning it up you
know what I hate that or what she would
say right but it's like closer to it and
I still got so many messages for people
that were like I don't know if you know
this maybe it's different in Tennessee
but we don't really say colors anymore
that kind of a it's like a [ __ ]
course I know that that's the point of
the joke is that it's antiquated
out-of-date ideal that she would have
and I may
King fun of it yeah but just the word
just calling referring to a bike person
as colored no matter the context sets
some people off and it's that whole
attitude that's like that is the reason
that so many people hate with yeah it's
that kind of thing yeah because it's
just ridiculous what about the idea that
so you you make that joke about your
great-great grandma and that people now
look at historical figures and try to
give them the morality of 2017 like I
would guess I don't know but I would
guess you're great program I probably
was a pretty decent woman didn't right
raised some kids and bah-bah-bah yes
maybe she had there were some racial
stuff there too which I got but that we
suddenly give our morality of today to
everyone else that's a really dangerous
thing to do isn't it yeah without a
doubt that's that's another thing to
like that's a big reason why I try to be
a little more like understanding or I'm
not just so immediately like I'll [ __ ]
you to people on the far right or
whatever because I've known so many of
them and loved them you know what I mean
like my grandpa but my grandfathers are
dead if they were here though they
probably would have voted for Donald
Trump right I love the [ __ ] out of both
of my grandpa and miss them all the time
you know what I mean and like people
just shouldn't but they were from
they're from a different time you're
gonna mean like they weren't bad people
but like both of them man's in words
know God he thought of it all the time
but like that was just it was like
that's just how people talked when they
were when they were growing up or over
their lives whatever I remember one time
it's just true story and this is this is
in my book too but there was a fight
between a white kid in the black kids in
the town downtown like the town square
of salon in my hometown when I was in
high school small town everybody's
talking about it because the white kid
got the [ __ ] beat out of it and
everybody was talking about it and so I
was at my grandpa's car lot the next day
and he asked me what was that about what
happened and I was like well I think you
know I think Jimmy called Jimmy called
Kyle the n-word or something something
like that and my grandpa goes Oh what
the hell do you want him to call him
Chinese
it is live because I okay yeah and like
it was he wasn't trying to be funny he
wasn't trying to you know like that that
was his genuine first thought and it
he's just a product of his time and
that's how so and that my grandfather
was born in 1935 so when you start
talking about people in the 1800's or
whatever yeah trying to apply today's
standards to them is ridiculous
no I mean I'm curious do you ever get it
the other way where you'll say something
about redneck culture and people that
are still part of that culture will be
like hey you know you're making us all
look like idiots or you're making us all
look backwards or whatever I get a lot
of and especially in my hometown I get a
lot of oh he's selling his people out
like that I'm just like exploiting them
for like a gimmick or whatever but it's
not a gimmick it is Who I am so I don't
look at it that way at all
so anybody groping me should know better
because as we talked about earlier like
I've always been this guy that none of
them should be surprised by this yeah
and I get a lot of that but no I
remember what I said earlier about
rednecks and not giving a damn where
people [ __ ] I don't get much of like you
know or you shouldn't be making fun of
me man you know or whatever like I'll
just get like [ __ ] you queer you know I
thought about that but not in a like
very very clear rhythm right not not in
the what yes I'm a queer to them like
not not otherwise that they're offended
by the redneck jokes they're offended by
my ideas yeah you know what I mean
that's about it I don't really get a lot
of like oh you're making us all look bad
because they genuinely for most part
don't give a [ __ ] how they look to other
groups of people or whatever yeah
there's almost really show how like
important comedy is to almost everything
because you know if you look at at
Foxworthy and those guys with the
redneck comedy tour that's what it's
called blue-collar bukata comedy tour
that that was finally an outlet for some
of these people that were talking about
to just have their [ __ ] hurt and that's
just an incredibly powerful thing yeah I
completely agree and totally think that
comedy is more important now than it's
been in a long time weirdly enough and I
didn't I didn't check this this is in
the middle
another interview for a UK magazine and
so I'm talking to this British reporter
and she was talking about she asked me a
question
apparently Armando Iannucci you know
that is yeah the EP for VP but he made
in the loop the movie before that in the
UK the thick of it I'm a huge fan of
that guy colossal panties when my
favorite comedy writers on planet earth
and she just and she's like did you hear
what he said the other day and I didn't
know I guess it was news over there
whatever and she said that according to
her he said that he thinks that it's
time to step away from joking about a
lot of these things because we need to
take it seriously and not joke about it
and I told her I was like well I still
love his work and I'm a huge fan but I
could not possibly disagree more
strongly with that yeah especially
you're talking about I'm a comedian yeah
he's a comedy writer you know like what
that's my whole job is to make fun of
[ __ ] and I think you need comedy in
times like this because it otherwise
it's just darkness you know I mean like
it makes it easier to deal with because
like yeah you know people do need to
talk about it seriously the people like
you know politicians and anti people are
actually in the field or whatever they
do need to take this [ __ ] seriously they
absolutely do because it's very serious
but I'm a comedian
I don't need good that's not my role our
role is to take the piss out of it yeah
to use you know his Rijn ocular and like
let's I don't know why we would stop now
you know I don't think it's more
important now than ever it is and again
if he if he didn't actually say that
then you know whatever well we're gonna
question it and send it directly to ya
right yeah but according to a British
reporter that was a quote from him and I
was I was just kind of floored like no
no it's the opposite I've seen a lot of
that though we're dry tommix I mean
people that I generally respect and like
where they've gone off the deep end
where it's like no they're not being
funny anymore
they're just preaching all the time and
it's like if George Carlin was around
and I say this on the show was every
week like every morning I wake up where
the hell is George Carlin when we need
him more than ever Express he would
still be being funny about this and
and that goes to prove your point yeah
that's what we need absolutely yeah well
we did it we did a New Yorker la guy and
a redneck we did an hour
this has been an hour I didn't look down
once we didn't stop we said we were
going to stop Lynn yeah we're all
dresser yeah we didn't even stop flew by
it flew by I have a feeling we're gonna
cross paths again I think so I hope so I
hope so too thanks for having me one
yeah she's only been on telly for not
even a month Keith and to be a month and
like four or five more days yeah well
you should you probably got to get a
spray tan right yeah yeah trainer yeah
up now you know you're eating carbs can
you golem and all the carbs yeah all the
car buy all the gluten dairy all that
I'm doing a piss-poor job of that
yeah that part of being a Californian we
did a me and Korey Andrew we came out
here and one of the first things we did
was shotgun from liquor always is in the
mod slits oh yeah I'm you know I'm
dipping my toes in the water small steps
yeah maybe both yeah all right well it
was a pleasure chatting pleasures all
mine
alright guys for more on Trey and to
find out his tour dates on the well-read
comedy tour check out facebook.com slash
cred crowded
[Music]
you
[Music]